video it's reminiscent of things that
are happening all over
Ukraine at the moment the front line
we're seeing in a small probably area of
Woodland
vast open areas of Ukraine interspersed
with little pockets of Woodland and
that's where Russian forces will be
setting up their defenses
and what you're seeing here is the
massively intense fighting that's
happening in small areas whether it's
along a wood line or whether it's
actually within the a larger wood
the sense of all of these bunkers you
can see here where they look very
makeshift but they absolutely work they
stop rockets and you're watching a
grenade being thrown in now to clear
that area
but obviously the ukrainians will be
paranoid that the Russians have survived
the initial onslaught
and here tragically is one of the
ukrainians has taken a hit one of his
comrades is pulling him clear while the
one of his fellows is providing covering
fire
[Applause]
I'm very struck by watching this that uh
there's a whole generation of people
brought up on um games
um Call of Duty and other such Games
first person shooter and that's what
this feels like when you first look at
it but of course there is no reset you
can't control that reset you can't say
right I've been killed let's come back
alive in another part of it for these
soldiers they are fighting it's kill or
be killed
and I can only imagine the adrenaline's
pouring through their bodies now they're
going through they've just cleared one
of the the bunkers they're it's a
complete mess but inevitably they're
pulling out guns uh ammunition machine
guns
you know you could call it looting you
could call it liberating but the harsh
reality
is that sustaining forces
on the front line is actually very
difficult they get through a lot of
ammunition and as you can see here the
Russians have loads of ammunition
um in their bunker so what this allows
is the ukrainians to self-sustain to
actually start using the Russians
weapons their ammunition against them
one of the ukrainians has just seen as
another Russian emplacement further up
you can see them liberating some hand
grenades that they're going to use to
clear the next spunker
um but of course the Russians know where
they're in place of Southern ukrainians
do not so there's a trap every step of
the way and the ukrainians have to be
very methodical
sort of working their way through and
even when there's an open Bunkie they
don't know where there's anything down
there imagine the fear going through
your body of that somebody might
suddenly jump up with a hand grenade or
a machine gun
so what we're seeing here now is that um
that ukrainians have found somebody
still alive in one of their the Russian
bunkers as ukrainians sat on the edge
there talking to the Russian because
basically they're giving them the chance
to come out alive or die in the bunker
and here's some footage said that from
the Drone allegedly of the Russians
running away generally they have a
headquarters so you have lots of out
placements where the bunkers are this
looks like they're running towards their
headquarters are sort of bigger enclosed
area
um where they would hope to have some
sanctuary
but the ukrainians will know that if
they just suddenly Advance on that they
could walk into a trap
um and inevitably the Russians will have
booby-trapped these Woodlands as well in
the winter which they we were fighting
they thought none of the leaves on the
trees would be there there wouldn't have
been any cover
whereas now you can start to see The
Greenery arriving provide some cover
from which both the which generally
favors the defense because they can be
hidden away
and of course that's the Infantry now
they've called upon tank support because
now they think they've got them pinned
down the Russians pinned down in their
headquarters
so now the best way to flush them out of
that or is to bring in the heavy armor
um so they will be pointing out to the
commander of the tank where to go what
the threat is
and there's not a lot that the Russians
can do at this stage and
what appears to be happening now is the
tank just drives into the Woodland and
drives over the top
of this Russian emplacement
um
and you can only imagine that there's
nothing the Russians can do here they
won't have effective anti-tank weapons
they'll have just been Laden with
smaller caliber Munitions and the Tank's
just going to roll backwards and
forwards now flushing out the remaining
Russian soldiers but this is really good
example of coordinator attack between
the tanks and the inventory in a really
confined area and I reiterate this is
happening all over Ukraine at the moment
which is why the casualties are so high
and as you can see at the bottom of the
screen there the ukrainians soldiers
just moving in really cautiously just to
uh to take over once the tank has
finished doing its damage
to that headquarters area
it's quite sobering I say this is not a
game this is uh
violence death and destruction being
wreaked all along the front line of
Ukraine
on a daily basis